well we know that this package was
seized after it arrived at Heathrow
Airport on the 29th of December and
according to the sun this package had
arrived in terminal 4 on a flight from
Oman it was in the hold of a passenger
jet and it was after some scanners went
off whilst it was on the way to a
freight shed where it was detected and
then seized by border four stars and the
sun report also state that the package
had originally come from Pakistan so
coming from Pakistan making its way to
Oman before being then flown to the UK
now understandably this is something
that would cause concern but something
of reassurance is the fact that the
systems designed to catch catch
something like this were in place and it
was detected we haven't had any
statement from the home office however
the Metropolitan Police have released a
statement and in that statement
Commander Richard Smith has said I want
to reassure the public that the amount
of contaminated material was extremely
small and has been assessed by experts
as opposing no threat to the public
Although our investigation remains
ongoing from our inquiries so far it
does not appear to be linked to any
direct threat as the public would expect
however we will continue to follow up on
all available lines of inquiry to ensure
this is definitely the case so important
takeaways and reassurances in that
message first of all it was a very small
amount of uranium in the package it
doesn't pose any direct threat to the
public and it hasn't been linked to any
known threats as investigations from
counter-terror police continue they'll
be working to identify how the package
arrived here in the first place and to
identify those who may be responsible
for its arrival